all righty
so after the huge big excitement
sleepless night for the Alan Costin
reasons well let's get some what is our
topic deep strategic thinking all right
we will get something like in into those
strategic thinking and actually one
interesting topic I believe that I might
have touched this topic in one of my
lectures in January little bit but it
will be interesting to revisit it in a
different well with just different games
and ideas is well I will put the
position and you will start telling me
so this is a position form a game of
Hikaru Nakamura st. Louis you know boy
you know how you wanna call him then
City City representative sometimes city
representatives there sometimes at least
in the past and plan number four in the
world in the present so we'll give him
the respect he deserved when he got this
position against against Grand Master
Joel Benjamin not a home boy in st.
Louis but being here playing us
championship quite several times and
former US Champion I think three times
so he will get also some respect and it
is why to play and I know that everyone
wants to play which move for White Queen
a fourth Julian
speaking for everyone and now the
question is what's the question Julia is
it good
oh maybe more precisely it's Queenie for
winning by false Oh No because after
Queen f4 you know I like those people
none of you is going to be those people
that we look at the position after queen
fo and say well after Queen F or it's
either door or white is waning
seriously wow that's impressive that's
impressive to say that right like white
the white is better after Queen s ball
nice no after Queen a for it's either
yes or no there's nothing in between not
maybe could be should be I think might
no no it's either yes white is winning
by false this leaf this and that all now
it's a draw so while I'm speaking Julian
is already super thinking in the
position winning although so we got in
position I would plate on the board
before we're gonna think in our head
that Julian King we exchanged those and
Julian brought his king hail King on c5
pawn on c6 and black king is on c8 I
think this we get by force after Queen
take take take take King here King here
King here king here King here these days
develop King here King on c5 or c6 what
do we have to
maybe I love them maybe a foe King me
five or a phone okay good
both of those moves are wrong but but no
it's good at that are you going to study
them off if you play a foe mr. Julian I
shall play what should I play is this
bliss tell you what should I play it's
not funny
I shall play King c7 let's see
Jinxy seven is good a five I should play
King to d8
so let's let you know in a moment of
generosity
let's get them take they take here here
here here there here here but uh okay
this was like false right I mean nothing
to do like you play queen fo you analyze
this position there's nothing else to
analyze fo you want a foe and I go King
c7 now a5
I shall go Oh King to d8 King this I
shall play here ah basics so close okay
now Rob King b5 King be fine beautiful
but we're gonna study actually something
from this no joke
I play King c7
a 400 back we talk once you talk again
maybe
a five good king here
we take King c5 I shall go him when
that's exactly the same position that
see look at this one to the same
position that we had in a six no okay
I should go here stalemate
so is it a door no not at all
not believing me okay so what to play
before here
here we are happy yeah before we fall we
[ __ ] we fight King these six King the
eight
crazy f3 I shall play this move
hmm
see seven I should play this move now if
I should play this so close credible so
you want to look again here you want to
admit it to draw no King the 8th King c8
a5
a phone call modulations on the fifth
sixth tenth we want the endgame and if I
played a six what would you play
seriously
yeah
yes so what did you study from this
engine Julien
zum-zum I'll tell you what I thought oh
my goodness it's almost like so stabbing
this thing never I started two things
when you have a microphone never never
knock on your chair never I kept
bursting I studied of course the
importance of seeing the simplification
is crucial we had we had such a lecture
I think in January actually about this
topic with different position this is
this is the first base of everything I
can exchange Queens I can go to opponent
game I have to get an outcome yes no I
have to but in the end game itself
mistakes kept happening here by the
crowd in in in the end game and what was
the mistake one mistake once you
understood that you don't want to touch
this point this point gives you the
flexibility to mean pretty much never be
in some zone because when this point
stays here you are in control of playing
a3 or playing a four at the right moment
you see you can get into this position
and all you need is to have this
position and your opponent ran out of
moves and then you play King districts
so if he's playing a five you will play
a three a four
no stalemate if you will play a six you
won't play a three that would be
horrible you will play a four you will
play a five and then you will move your
king if you touch this pawn earlier at
any moment if this point gun you gave
away for free your possibility to decide
on a Tempe whether you need whether you
are zero or plus one or whatever however
you want to call it whether you need to
equalize your opponent or you need to
give him a move touching this pawn no
more win and this is so important so
many many end games I've seen and let
them out I mean okay some may be
somewhat lower level just people move
the pieces oh okay I can
my PO what what does it mean move this
pawn in a pawn endgame
I mean how you win pawn end games okay
there are few ways to win one you have
five extra pawns that's not a bad way to
win but the other way if you don't have
them and if it's really counting the
moves this is your oxygen this is you're
gonna live or die by how many spare
moves do you have in the crucial
position by touching this pawn you touch
the spare move so that's what we started
from this one position number two this I
think was actually played here I'm not I
think was played in a match pon mi over
against Nakamura in st. Louis 2000 till
every okay let's say this is the
position and it is black to play so here
several questions
I mean basically once again quite simple
what is black subjective and how should
black achieve it and that's all what is
black subjective and how should black
achieve it if you understand the
objective it's a big step if we find out
to get it will win the game on the spot
get the Queen's off perfect okay you
have a pawn up the where the kings are
is crucial if you can get the Queens of
the board it's over finished history how
to get it
that's it waiting at the pig queen III
check okay King H ho 25 better so which
line would you play 25 I play Queen h4
King g3 and then Queen a5 next move this
is why this is this is okay I think
nakum overplayed Queen III it's very
simple if you get the right idea Queen
III and here you know many people
suggest this move with the idea that
this is finished but if you're white
what would you play would you play King
h3 you will play g4 black is winning
here okay two pawns up is winning but
but is this a position that blacks
should resign like should not resign him
I mean it's most likely going to lose
but it's not a position to resign on the
spot it's not I would not resign I would
not I mean black is playing here sorry
white I mean okay it's they're always
thumper patch some checks on this you
don't design in this position on the
other hand and that's why winning the
pawn is not that impressive on the other
hand if we play for example I'll show
you how the game finished you can play
decent white just resign very simple
King goes to g4 or
h3 we're gonna play Queen e6 if King
goes to g3 Queen g5 and doesn't matter
where it goes Queen a5 exchanges which
is exactly the same as Queen e5 check
drank and so on okay so very easy way to
think about it exchange the Queen's
finding the right sequence to really
exchange the Queen's not win another
poor not allowed to opponent any escape
from death because this is resign the
other position you're going to play for
another three
maybe win maybe make a door alright good
that that idea is good okay another
position this is the game in a canoe
again since the piano I think from the
bass now the Kings tournament in Romania
may be 2010 something like that and why
it is to play here and now you're going
to think and tell me how should white be
playing here
geez okay I will let other people think
and then we will discuss your idea
any other thoughts of g6 is the only
move seriously okay so let's see these
this this right okay I'll just push the
pawn I guess
and then I'll take here you gave they're
quite quite a lot play okay I don't want
to give the pawn okay so let's see so
Julian what is your idea after Jesus did
you see that the pawn is taken okay I'll
take King take King f6 Knight h4
okay let's let's look at that
I'll play these
right well ladies
in 96 I will go king of six you know I
have to defend the pawn
not so easy probably waiting for white
also disposition but I don't know but
that's a easier way and it still
involves g6 - well no maybe also decent
idea no ok white is in control but you
see maybe maybe 9205 somehow will win
actually I think it probably might in
some versions but but when you when
there is some there is such amount of
reduced material on the board even if
it's not on you think about it
after g6 take take taking before those
pawns cannot move Knight well and where
you want to go this one that's exactly
what was played I mean I think it will I
think 92 was played but it doesn't
matter you want to go from hill or you
want to go from here I think it's
exactly the same length exactly exactly
you want a clear answer here of course
the bishop can go whatever but then okay
then it's just completely paralyzed like
he he has to take take take
yeah I want to see if there is any
difference between here no difference
whatsoever this was played these days
these days something like that I mean
this is something like this okay two
points up in its winning because he will
play the six and the King goes - that's
pretty much of the game how they game
finished so you want a
clear clear conclusion here like
seriously like not not yes not maybe not
I'm better not it looks winning it looks
winning is not enough
it looks winning when to say it looks
winning is okay you sacrifice such a
huge mass impossible to calculate
everything but kind of like your
instinct your chest knowledge tells you
there is no defense there you cannot
completely prove it right you cannot
prove it like white one line equation
and prove it here you want to prove it
here that's that's what we just did we
proved it play g6 we got the idea of
going for the b5 pawn and then and this
one was this one was over okay so that
so that part of proving it is as
critical as possible for example I will
I will give you two other examples of
things like that well one of them okay
I actually one of them is a game played
by friend of mine in the u.s.
championship actually it wasn't played
after I don't know gosh like six hours I
mean that was crazy
timo garea played in the last time it
was wasn't for spot 102 but he showed
third three and four it only shook so
this this end game was reached to move
82 after they play quite quite a long
game I mean let's see it was 90 30 plus
30 seconds increments oh they played for
hours
plus they got very quickly let's
calculate it like 4900 seconds so it was
five five and a half hours about game
tiny let's say up until this moment
white was oh it was crazy game white was
better than he was lost actually at some
point and then I think if cornered hot
would have won I think he would have
tied if I'm not mistaken with Ramirez in
Kamsky with six and a half was really
a crazy action then white was winning
and his King was all over the boat then
it was perpetual somehow they got this
really really really crazy game and it's
interesting first looking at the
position you are going to say that this
position is though of course it's and it
probably is but if you have to choose a
side which side would you choose tiny
bit black sail on wide black because but
if you can start checking and then what
I mean yeah maybe for a rule that you
had more checks and excellent but for
normal chess white white is better in
Queen endgame Queen endgame what
did--what decides such engines is the
Kings the King the kings decides Queens
endgame and whitest white King is better
than black it should be a draw but the
problem is that what is White's plan
it's quite incredible white wants to
bring his king and threaten exchange of
Queens and this King is so much closer
to the pawn black cannot exchange black
will move the Queen then white will move
is Queen here all the time with those
ideas it should be a draw because black
should keep an eye on this point but
black is of course worst I mean with
this weed if King and if one material
how can black be better still if this
was in Russia no no you wouldn't be
laughing like saying telling me black is
better here but King 816 okay you can
also see the players at two minutes and
okay they get some increment and here is
my question what do we think about this
position right now and why bizarre hey
I've seen that look what does he want
for me
okay so what is this position Oh
beautiful the checks the Julian like so
much so I can make a draw does white
have more than a tall
you can fall screen train how can you
fall screen to it hmm I didn't say no
why joy good people are like going with
but it's a good time scary like you know
people say stuff say aha
I didn't say that you know like did
someone hear it very good not and then
people learn to think ball before they
say things so can you fall screen right
yes how black to play so so let's do it
if black King go to 8 6 or to g6 then 26
and okay and they porn end game is
winning yeah because the king is going
to go to anyway
okay if the King goes to g8 or f8
how do we false Queen to it Queenie 8
Queen e7 that's forcing a queen trade
I'm impressed
and if King of 7
black his idea I mean Queenie six I
think was played and black resigned King
GA King G 727 Queen afraid Jack and
Queen seven so what seemingly looked
like a completely completely innocent
endgame innocent engine completely
turned out that forcing the Queen trade
this decided US Championship in some way
and you know let me just see if I am
correct about cornered halt finish which
- yeah look you finished with - they
have he was winning before so he could
have finished with six and a half
together with champion on mirrors and
definitely issued could have made a draw
be here although again before Timo was
winning but a great game you know really
like five and a half hours and being
decided like that if you think that this
is so uncommon then let me show you a
little bit stronger players then than
those magic okay so there's probably one
player in the world that can play those
positions you know to be to be honest
okay it was incredible they played very
very young Magnus Carlsen I mean 16 and
a half years old playing in their
candidate matches after he qualified
when he was 15 from the World Cup in
2005 so 16 and a half Magnus Carlsen
playing against I think I wanna knows
player number four in the world at that
time 2007 there was Kramnik an oncoming
Topalov I think I've only on was fourth
so amazing Carson 16 and they happen Wow
I mean gave him such a match just
unbelievable the first six games were
draw - it was the best out of six then
they played for Rapids this is game
number 10 in the rapid and Carlson is -1
he lost in game 7
so playing until the last pawn is no
joke really playing until the last
onion 1 the two blades games then
qualified and made it
I think qualified and made it to the
tournament in Mexico which was won by an
aunt who became the world champion but
what is this position well what do we
think about this position is it draw
White's better is why better is it a
draw white is better this I can tell but
is it a door
yes no no shouldn't be that much
thinking waning why the question dick
look what what did what did we say is
most important in Queens endgame the
Kings if black King would have been
somewhere here we could be speaking
whether it's ad or not whether they will
be checked there and then it would be a
big long discussion the king is here
what's the discussion there's no
discussion it's of course they're
completely completely nothing nothing
draw like no no even advantage here
let's let's put computer why can't I put
computer I don't know no computer
yeah sorry here put computer right now
zero - what do you get one this computer
is so generous you put it on Houdini
like nothing zero to something like
insane nothing plus +1 in those ten
games is nothing if it's raining
computer should be depends either 8 + 3
4 5 Oh already seeing checkmate if he is
deep enough nothing what dude this is of
course completely insanely dead drop
nothing nothing nothing to see here the
king is here I mean does perpetual then
but look what happened here well what
what black should be careful and again
it's a rapid game 25 minutes plus 10
seconds increment and again move 81
canons assume there were with 10 20
seconds each Oh check yeah this already
I mean okay I understand this is ok but
why not to go up I don't know ok gate 6
ok you give some check I go down you
move the pawn after checking or checking
you and and and whenever we will
exchange Queens if my king is here and
you already touch the phone all I need
to do is just get the opposition and
that's it right ok so that's why I like
the King a bit up ok check
and what is this position now
threatening checkmate one two three four
checkmate okay how to stop those
checkmate
by giving a check we're about to give a
check
Queen B 1 in what she'll white play
after Queen B 1 o Queen c2
I mean maybe to draw one of them green
a5 and what will black play after Queen
a5
maybe resign no maybe resign because if
Queen b6 Queen f6 and opponent game is
winning
well what white white is in the white
square and if not well this is checkmate
idea in this so resign that's how Carson
tied the match like after ten games
unbelievable well but I want this alone
yun do these stuff like many people
would be like really devastated mean
losing something like this is painful
like really painful but he went and he
wanted to blitz games like really really
very very easily like just killed him
but you know you'd similarities from
this move actually almost identical in
the way of the determining move 84 I
think the other one was really 84 the
pawn there was a pawn here they
transitioned to a winning pawn endgame
from Queen Ian's games you know this is
how we started we started with first
game of Nakamura against Benjamin then
we've seen another game of Ponemah off
Nakamura then we have seen not Queen
endgame but other endgame that again
let's a make changes and I just wanted
to show another Recaro game in back to 2
Queen and games team of against cornered
halt in the u.s. championship in this
one I really don't like once again this
getting back with the King of course
it's still able after it I think that
again with 10 seconds it's not easy or
20 seconds but pretty much I guess many
other moves like Queenie for for example
Queenie for should be a draw I mean I
don't I don't see any anyway why Queenie
for is not a draw I mean let let just
okay let's play Queenie for and put it
for a second on the computer and if he's
showing forced mate then I am been okay
again but yeah this is what you get I
mean just Queenie for put the cube the
Queen's centralized square tiny bit be
careful not to play let's show it on the
board
Queen eight seven is not so cool because
Julian will take take and then will tell
me hey dude
can't you see I'm getting the opposition
and be so happy but if you will play
Queen if oh okay then after King age
five okay now we can play Queen eight
seven and now black gets the opposition
no again of course I won Yin would make
dua 999 out of thousand this was the one
important one that I didn't but it's the
spots of the kings in the false
exchanges that are crucial for those end
games all right do we have any questions
or should we get a good sleep before
3:30 to see their games